for millions of years the earth has been
perfectly good at absorbing carbon
dioxide our forests seas and streams
suck the gas up acting as natural carbon
sinks that was until humans came along
and tipped the scales if we continue to
burn fossil fuels at ever rising rates
we could warm the planet by 7 and 9
degrees Fahrenheit by the end of the
century and the impacts of that would be
catastrophic there have been various
attempts to capture this harmful co2 but
they've all come with significant
compromise until now five four three two
one
igniter on the reason this team is so
happy is because they've just completed
the first successful ignition of the
first co2 powered turbine in the world's
first carbon neutral natural gas power
plant their company is called net power
it'll be the first truly zero emission
power plant in the world in a
traditional gas power plant the burning
gas creates steam which turns a power
generating turbine creating a lot of
excess co2 in the process previous
attempts to capture that co2 have
reduced efficiency and led to higher
costs of production generally it was
thought that carbon capture on natural
gas was not economic so what we had to
do was start with a blank sheet of paper
enter this man Rodney alum he developed
the system now referred to as the alum
cycle I set myself the objective of
devising something which would remove
hundred percent of the co2 from the
fossil fuel with no increase in the cost
of electricity
Rodney actually did most of his work on
what's called quadrille paper he has a
point five millimeter mechanical pencil
and a four function calculator and
booked tables to look up his data when a
complex computer model was created to
check Rodney's calculations
Rodney's pretty much right I selected
co2 is the fluid in the turbine rather
than the steam or air which we use
previously in steam systems or gas
turbine systems and it worked we in
effect turned the problem into the
solution in Rodney's design since the
co2 is used to spin the turbine and as
part of an entirely closed loop it never
enters the atmosphere it's captured by
default and because the co2 power system
is just as efficient as traditional
natural gas plants the cost per kilowatt
hour is the same we've designed a power
cycle that is cheaper and cleaner rather
than more costly imagine when you have
economics driving a solution instead of
policy aspirations
although the co2 never enters the
atmosphere the alum cycle still
generates a carbon by-product which
leaves us with the problem of what to do
with all that carbon
[Music]
4,000 miles away engineers in Iceland
have an interesting take on how to keep
the captured co2 out of the atmosphere
shoving it directly into the ground
[Music]
effects is an R&D project that we
started about 12 years ago with the
objective of developing methods and
technologies for capturing otherwise
emitted co2 injecting it into basaltic
formations we know that certain chemical
processes are already happening in
nature for example in vicinity of
volcanoes the co2 dissolves into
groundwater and forms new types of rock
by interacting with ourselves and we
thought why not try and accelerate this
process at an industrial scale very
simply karbix takes the captured carbon
and mixes it with water which basically
creates seltzer
they'd then take the fizzy liquid and
inject it deep into the earth where the
carbon chemically bonds to the basalt
rock instead of co2 turning into rock in
hundreds to thousands of years this
would happen within the timeframe of a
few years here we have an example of a
beam this is then a small fracture where
we would have dissolved part of the
Passats and then we fill it up again
with the carbonates and that's where we
see these pores filling up with coal
sites
if we take all a soft available on earth
theoretically we could use it to
permanently store much more than all co2
that we would emit from burning all
fossil fuel available globally but carb
fix is still operating at a small scale
and it would take serious interest from
industries and governments to grow to a
size that would affect climate change
worldwide in the meantime net power
won't be burying its co2 under the
ground they'll be selling it for cold
hard cash because for the first time we
capture carbon dioxide at very
inexpensive prices we open up whole new
industries for reuse and recycling co2
that can be useful in building materials
chemicals plastics in a myriad of other
applications but one of the most common
uses of industrial co2 is actually
extracting fossil fuels from the ground
in the u.s. you're actually injecting
over 20 million tons a year of co2 for
enhanced or recovery at the moment I
think I think if you do if you're
sensible about the way that hydrocarbons
are used and you have a integrated idea
as to how you're going to how you're
gonna utilize that hydrocarbon in a
clean way and that part is key if net
powers excess co2 essentially leads to
more oil being extracted it's not a
stretch to imagine it will mostly be
used in traditional carbon spewing
plants not clean ones like net power it
very much appears that you know the age
of fossil fuels is likely coming to a
close some of these technologies for
capturing a sequestering carbon might
help provide sort of that bridge it's
going to take a decade or two to to
really make that transition in our
global energy economy
I'm very optimistic all the technologies
there and we just need the will
that's really happening now if we really
want to succeed in in fighting climate
change that we need to bring down the
co2 levels in the atmosphere there is no
silver bullet there is no one solution
we have to use all the methods available
[Music]